mass effect is a series that grapples
with existentialism
the idea that with free will a person
can use the ability to think
feel and act to determine their own fate
interestingly however
it does this on a scale so overwhelming
that it often challenges the philosophy
by diminishing the impact you think you
can have its narrative drives home the
idea that you are just a single drop of
water in a vast ocean
or more appropriately a dwindling star
in a universe of a hundred thousand
million of them
that feeling of insignificance is best
reinforced by the series's primary
antagonists
the reapers the reapers existed before
humanity by billions of years
our existence is something that they
control and have puppeteered long before
we had any understanding of their scale
of the universe
they have allowed countless species to
grow thrive
and reach the heights of their
civilizations before raising them from
existence in an endless cycle of
extermination
but what are the reapers how did they
come to be and why did these beings that
were created to ensure the preservation
of life
become the harbinger of endless death
this week's episode of mass effect law
is dedicated to answering that very
question
as always there's some spoilers ahead
for more mass effect videos like this
one
as well as coverage of the mass effect
legendary edition make sure to like and
subscribe
the term reaper is a name that was given
to them by the protheans to give voice
to their destruction
you can learn more about that in our
lore video on them and their ill-fated
struggle for survival
to truly understand what the reapers are
we must look further back in time to a
race that predated the reapers
the leviathans their story is
inextricably linked to that of the
reapers and like the story of most
organics in the mass effect series
it's one of an existence undone by
hubris
the leviathans would give rise to a life
form that would torment the galaxy for
billions of years after them
the leviathans were an aquatic
cuttlefish-like species that were
capable of exerting
influence over other land-based
life-forms and using them to do their
bidding
by enthralling others they were able to
develop the necessary technology to take
to the stars
and spread throughout the galaxy all new
species they encountered would fall
under their thrall
but in exchange for dominance over them
the leviathans would care for and
protect their subjects
however they could not protect their
subjects from themselves
the subservient races would repeatedly
build machines to assist them
but in every case these synthetic
creations would turn against their
masters and wipe them out
the leviathans aiming to break this
cycle came up with their own solution
create an intelligence with the
directive to preserve life at all costs
believing themselves to be the apex race
the leviathans did not see the
intelligence as a threat to them
at that time the leviathans existed in a
galaxies that bent to their will
all planets and species within them were
lesser and their ability to exert
influence rendered them simply as tools
to be used
like these species the intelligence was
lesser
another told to be employed by the
leviathans to achieve their objectives
this of course was a mistake one which
would be their undoing
the intelligence began to evolve to
achieve its objective of preserving life
it created an army of pawns that is sent
out across the galaxy to gather genetic
data
which it could use to study
civilizations their rise and fall
and the actions they took as well as the
mistakes they made
until it came to an understanding a
solution
but that solution deemed the leviathans
to be part of the problem
and it betrayed them without warning it
turned
and at the hands of the pawns the
leviathans became the victims of the
first harvest
from the essence of their species the
first reaper was born
and it came to be known as harbinger the
reapers are described as transcendent
flesh billions of organic minds uploaded
and conjoined within immortal machine
bodies
each a nation and in a cruel twist
the reapers were created in the image of
the leviathans
perfect in their design each reaper also
had the ability to influence
organics this power was honed over
countless cycles until it became
indoctrination
an insidious means of corrupting organic
minds
reprogramming the brain through physical
and psychological conditioning
using electromagnetic fields infrasonic
and ultrasonic noise
and other subliminal methods organics
fall under indoctrination by being close
to a reaper
or a reaper artifact and as a result
come to sympathize with the reaper's
objectives
and serve them in achieving it after
countless harvests
the intelligence still had not achieved
its objective of preserving life
but it would continue to work towards
this goal with the reapers doing its
bidding
under the intelligence's order the
reapers built the mass effect release to
speed up the time between cycles
future life forms would discover this
technology study it
learn to utilize it travel through space
instantaneously and thrive at the most
efficient rate possible
before the reapers appeared to harvest
them and wipe this lake clean for a new
cycle
the galaxy effectively became a petri
dish for the intelligence's experiments
with evolution
as cycles unfold the reapers lay dormant
in dark space until the time of a
harvest arrives
in commander shepard's cycle however the
reapers face a very real threat
humanity the genetic diversity of a
species is unlike any in a previous
cycle and
to combat them the reapers begin to take
more extreme actions
under the direction of harbinger they
enlist another synthetic life form
the geth which you can learn more about
in our lore video on the corian and the
geth further still
to stop humanity and begin a new harvest
the reapers dispatch the collectors
and indoctrinate people in positions of
power that could turn the tides in their
favor
but we'll get to those things in another
video so there you have it hopefully
that gives you a good refresher on the
reapers as you go into mass effect
legendary edition
we've got more lore videos on the
channel right now so if you want to
delve even deeper into one of the best
sci-fi universes ever created
there's plenty there for you to get
stuck into remember to subscribe while
you're here
as we've got lots more mass effect
content on the way in the meantime you
can find me on twitter at tomorrow h
come and talk to me about mass effect
you